And with that, that is going to wrap things up for this video tutorial.
So we first started this video tutorial by creating a new landscape.
We then took a look at some of the tools that we could use to sculpt our landscape.
We then took a look at how we could create a material that allowed us to paint different
landscape layers, giving the illusion that we had things like brass, rocks, and dirt.
And then finally, we finished up with looking at how we can use the foliage tool to apply
various bits of foliage to the landscape and paint and interact with those foliage actors
so that we can adjust them or scale them or even delete them.
With that said, I want to thank everybody for listening.
It was my pleasure having you and I will see you next time.